[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mit heinz wolf
uns marietta slomka guten abend rund
64.000 gemeldeten neuinfektionen gestern
waren es 53.000 dürfte nicht mehr lange
dauern dann sind wir bei täglich hundert
tausend und selbst diese gigantischen
zahlen sind in wahrheit ja noch höher
denn die gesundheitsämter kommen mit dem
melden nicht mehr hinterher außerdem
werden nicht alle infektionen erkannt
die viren aber eifrig weiter gegeben
angesichts dieses geschehens bemüht sich
die innige mehrheit der gesellschaft um
ihre auffrischungsimpfungen die
ärzteschaft spritzt was das zeug hält
und reagiert jetzt konsterniert auf die
ankündigung des noch
gesundheitsministers sparen den bayern
tag im stoff zu deckeln damit bereits
gekaufte moderner dosen nicht vergammeln
frankfurt weiter richtet
eine so lange schlange haben sie ihm
üben büren lange nicht gesehen offene
impfaktion bei dr windmann die meisten
warten aufs boostern viele haben bisher
nicht mal den ersten peaks wer nur der
impfstoff reicht wir sind in der lage
viel mehr patienten zu impfen als noch
vor einer woche aber wir sind immer noch
gebunden an die impf mengen die wir vor
zwei wochen bestellt haben es ist also
kurzfristig gar nicht möglich gewesen
jetzt die impfstoffmenge zu erhöhen
wie auch immer man sucht nach gründen
aber man läuft dagegen irgendeine
bürokratischen apparat ärger über
bürokratie auch in berlin konkret ein
brief aus dem
bundesgesundheitsministerium
zuerst so heißt es sollte nicht bei
montech verimpft werden sondern vakzine
von moderner sie verfielen anfang
nächsten jahres die länder laufen sturm
patientinnen und patienten sind
einbestellt die impfbereitschaft ist
hoch und wir müssen das jetzt
unterstützen wir brauchen den turbo und
keine handbremse deswegen darf es keine
begrenzungen bei beyond im moment geben
in berlin jedoch widerspricht das sei
genug impfstoff für alle da sagt der
minister allein nächste woche werden
sechs millionen dosen von biontech
ausgeliefert das heißt aber auch unser
lager läuft gerade leer und deswegen
müssen wir eben zusätzlich zum impfstoff
von bayon tag auch den von moderner
stärker wieder mit einsetzen beides gute
sichere und wirksame eben stoffe gerade
auch für die auffrischimpfung auch
mediziner beruhigen beide impfstoffe
schützten mindestens gleichwertig es ist
vielleicht sogar gut moderner als auch
durch impfung zu verwenden weil die
konzentration etwas höher ist und
dadurch das maximale an gewundert wort
herausgeholt werden kann der andrang auf
7 führen wie hier neben büren bleibt
hoch eine impfpflicht für alle jedoch
wie in österreich will die neue ampel
koalition bisher nicht eine allgemeine
endlich dass es die debatte zur falschen
zeit wir müssen uns jetzt darauf
konzentrieren erst mal die vierte welle
in den griff zu bekommen und darüber die
impfpflicht keinen bartha klassen können
in spanien wurden alle bürgerinnen und
bürger angeschrieben und haben
impftermin angeboten bekommen es wird
niederschwellig geimpft auch am strand
und in israel ist die impfquote viel
höher ohne impfpflicht einfach durch
niederschwellige angebote das brauchen
wir in deutschland auch die lage
jedenfalls ist ernst nicht nur in
ibbenbüren und der winter hat noch nicht
mal angefangen
eines muss man verschwörungs gläubigen
impfgegnern lassen keine fantasie ist
ihnen zu blöd vor der großdemo heute in
wien warten sie sich gegenseitig auf
social media davor dass impfstoffe aus
der kanalisation in ihrer beine
gestochen oder von polizeihubschraubern
auf sie herunter gespült würden prompt
sah man einige demonstranten bei
strahlenden sonnenschein mit
regenschirmen und die schrauben
aufmarschieren mit den protesten beginnt
unser chromatik den christian von
rechenberg heute zusammengestellt hat
[Musik]
sie behaupten österreich sei eine
diktatur und die verschärften coroner
regeln faschismus anderen ging es eher
um die sache lockdown und impfpflicht da
wollen viele österreicher nicht
mitmachen etwa 35.000 gingen heute in
wien auf die straße aufgerufen zum
protest hatte unter anderem die
rechtspopulistische fpö auch neonazis
und hooligans marschierten mit die
polizei war vorbereitet mit mehr als
1300 einsatzkräfte trotz einiger
festnahmen blieb der protest relativ
ruhig
bereits gestern eskalierte in rotterdam
ein nicht angemeldeter corona protest in
einer orgie der gewalt so nannte ist der
bürgermeister aus dem ganzen land zog
die polizeikräfte zusammenstand zum teil
so heißt es hemmungslosem kriminellem
verhalten gegenüber mehrfach zogen
beamte ihre waffen schossen erst zur
warnung in die luft dann in zwei fällen
gezielt auf die angreifer aus notwehr
diese vorfälle werden nun untersucht
mehrere verletzte mindestens 50
festnahmen
werder bremens trainer tritt ab und das
hat etwas mit corona zu tun denn markus
anfangen soll ein gefälschtes zertifikat
genutzt haben jetzt ermittelt die
staatsanwaltschaft und hat anfangs
impfpass beschlagnahmt er beteuert seine
unschuld und trat als trainer dennoch
zurück mit ihm seinen co florian junge
warum die staatsanwaltschaft auch gegen
ihn ermittelt nicht bekannt
es sind ja nicht nur die erkrankten die
akut auf übervollen intensivstationen
liegen die korona pandemie wird unser
gesundheitssystem noch auf andere weise
langfristig belasten und übrigens auch
kosten verursachen die sich noch gar
nicht abschätzen lassen durch long cobit
nach jetzigem wissenstand trifft es
ungefähr zehn prozent der infizierten
auch solche die zunächst einen eher
milden verlauf hatten die symptome sind
vielfältig die diagnose nicht leicht die
therapie noch schwieriger die
reha-klinik heiligendamm hat sich als
eine der ersten auf longo wird patienten
spezialisiert
nach anderthalb jahren erfahrung zieht
sie nun eine erste bilanz susanne sein
berichtet
monatelang war andrea link komplett ans
bett gefesselt extremer schöpft durch
einen reha-aufenthalt und die betreuung
in einer ko witt ambulanz dort hatte die
ehemalige leistungssportlerin aller
verordneten übungen mitgemacht bis ihr
körper streikte
und dann dachte mir na ja der kopf hat
aber nix dann strenge mir einfach ein
bisschen mehr an und dann wird es schon
wieder werden und hab halt fleißig
weiter mitgemacht
was das sich leider erst im nachhinein
gezeigt hat dass das falsch war
seitdem geht ohne rollstuhl gar nichts
mehr die 47 jährige hatte ihren körper
völlig überlastet angespornt durch ärzte
und therapeuten an der rehaklinik
heiligendamm wollen sie herausfinden wie
eine reha bei longo wird diagnose
aussehen sollte und was sie leisten kann
dazu werden hier und an anderen kliniken
300 patienten während und nach der reha
untersucht und befragt erste erkenntnis
beim häufig auftretenden fertig also
erschöpfungssyndrom müssen ärzte
umdenken
müssen uns auf und der vorstellung
verabschieden dass wir diese patienten
antreiben müssen dass wir sie mehr
fordern müssen sondern wir müssen eher
bremsen und aufpassen dass die patienten
nicht selbstständig in so eine
überlastungsreaktion hineinlaufen so
entscheidet andrea lingen jetzt zusammen
mit den therapeuten welche anwendungen
ihr gut tun und wann etwas zu viel wird
so erholt sie sich seit drei wochen
langsam und bestätigt damit ein weiteres
studienergebnis von einer passenden reha
können longo witt patienten sehr
profitieren die allermeisten symptome
zum beispiel kurzatmigkeit
abgeschlagenheit müdigkeit schmerzen im
brustkorb werden statistisch signifikant
besser und das freut uns sehr aber
gerade bei diesem patientenkollektiv
haben wir gedacht dass die reha
möglicherweise ein bisschen
stabilisieren kann ein werden nicht
erwartet dass es wirklich so
so gute ergebnisse
daraus hervorgehen jedes einzelne
symptom bei lankowitz muss individuell
behandelt werden das ist der ansatz den
sie in heiligendamm verfolgen und es ist
bisher die einzige hoffnung auf
besserung doch immer noch stoßen
betroffene wie alena kittler bei ärzten
auf unverständnis die 26-jährige kann
seit ihrer corvette erkrankung nicht
mehr arbeiten ihr arzt glaubt ihr nicht
und er stellt dir indirekt zu simulieren
ganz viel unwissen immer
sehr vielen ärzten glaube ich auch
einfach eine art von
handlungsunfähigkeit dass sie gar nicht
wissen was sie tun sollen und dann die
in dieser haltung kommen in heiligendamm
wollen die studienleiter bis ende 2023
einen leitfaden für eine reha bei longo
wird entwickeln als anhaltspunkt für
ärzte und kliniken
angesichts der unfassbar vielen neuen
infektionen werden solche rehakliniken
nur für sehr sehr viele menschen
benötigt werden menschen die für lange
zeit nicht arbeitsfähig sind allein das
sollte eigentlich jeden motivieren die
infektionszahlen niedrig zu halten
erstaunlicherweise gelingt dass
mancherorts auf die stadt münster zum
beispiel auch dort steigen zwar aktuell
die zahlen aber auf einem deutlich
niedrigeren niveau als der
bundesdurchschnitt die sieben tage
incidents liegt bundesweit heute bei 362
in den hotspots in bayern bei über 1000
und in münster bei 144
das war auch schon den ersten corona
wählen so dass die westfälische
universitätsstadt das virus besser im
griff hatte wie macht sie das dazu
tadeusz parat
die meisten buden stehen schon und in
wenigen tagen geht es los alle
schausteller auf dem münsteraner
weihnachtsmarkt hoffen auf möglichst
viele besucher und möglichst viel umsatz
doch die sorge ist groß dass jetzt alles
wieder abgeblasen wird wir hoffen nur
dass er die 30 tage auch stattfindet
weil einige sage schon nikolaus am 6
häufig gehen die lichter ausgehen dass
die lichter an bleiben dafür spricht
dass münster bislang alle corona wellen
gut weggesteckt hat doch wie schafft die
stadt das was ist das erfolgsrezept das
krisen management arbeite sehr effektiv
sagt peter münster ehemaliger ärztlicher
leiter des infozentrums und booster
impfungen seine münster bereits anfang
september thema gewesen insgesamt ist
die impfquote bemerkenswert als das
impfzentrum sein dienst eingestellt hat
kurz vor ende september hatten wir
bereits fast herdenimmunität erreicht
das heißt die über 60 über 65 jährigen
hatten wir zu über 95 prozent geimpft
das fordert die whu 90 prozent und in
dem bereich 18 bis 59 jährige war auch
schon bei 84 prozent da hätte die whu 85
prozent als definition von herrn
mobilität gefordert die vergleichsweise
niedrige inzidenz frank münster wohl
auch anderen faktoren fast 40 prozent
fahren hier mit dem rad allein das senkt
das ansteckungsrisiko
außerdem ist die sozial und
arbeitsstruktur geprägt von universität
verwaltungen und behörden
sozialschichten die den strengen corona
kurs der stadt größtenteils befürworten
wenn man sagt wir machen zweig und dann
konsequent erhalt auch mit kontrollen
ich hätte auch kein problem damit wenn
es einlasskontrollen gelbe dabei dann
ist alles gut ich finde es ganz gut dass
sie auf jeden fall jetzt ein bisschen
strenger werden bringt halt die leute
auch ein bisschen dazu sich eher zu
impfen im kampf gegen korona schöpfe
münster schon immer alle
verwaltungsrechtlichen möglichkeiten aus
sagt krisenstabsleiter wolfgang heuer
verstöße gegen die zweijährige lauf
weihnachtsmärkten sollen 250 euro
bußgeld kosten das ist in jedem fall
kein kleines bußgeld ich halte es für
angemessen angesichts anderthalb jahre
information zu dem was erwartet und
verlangt werden kann da sich noch
rauszureden man hätte es vielleicht
nicht wissen können dass glaube ich geht
nicht mehr klare regeln klare kante das
beispiel münster zeigt das beherzt das
krisen-management zum erfolg führt
[Musik]
auch olaf scholz rief heute zum impfen
und postern auf außerdem äußerte er sich
zum stand der koalitionsverhandlungen
damit wenn die nachrichten von heinz
volk herr scholz sagte auf dem
landesparteitag der spd in brandenburg
spd grüne und fdp hätten etwas gemeinsam
das genau jetzt notwendig sei nämlich
eine vorstellung davon wie es
weitergehen soll in der gesellschaft
eine fortschritt idee und diese
fortschritts vorstellung
zusammenzuführen das sei jetzt die große
aufgabe wenn man einen koalitionsvertrag
verhandelt
die grünen co vorsitzende berbalk macht
auf einem parallel tagenden
landesparteitag ihrer partei in potsdam
deutlich es müsse klar sein dass
klimaschutz nicht ein einzelnes kapitel
in diesem koalitionsvertrag sein könne
klimaneutralität müsse leitlinie in
jedem politikbereich sein
mehrere tausend menschen haben in paris
gegen gewalt an frauen demonstriert sie
forderten unter anderem die regierung
solle zusätzliches geld bereitstellen
etwa um mehr frauenhäuser einzurichten
nach angaben von aktivistinnen sind in
diesem jahr in frankreich bereits
mindestens 101 frauen von ihren partnern
oder ex-partner getötet worden die
kundgebung war teil einer weltweiten
aktionswoche zum internationalen tag
gegen gewalt an frauen
in den usa ist deswegen eines
umstrittenen freispruchs an vielen orten
zu protesten gekommen dabei geht es um
den fall eines heute 18 jährigen er hat
im vergangenen jahr bei anti rassismus
protesten in kenia im bundesstaat
wisconsin zwei demonstranten erschossen
seine anwälte erklärten
er habe in notwehr gehandelt
und jetzt die lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr 8 24
26 31 40 47 superzahl 7 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 55 6
auch die wetteraussichten für morgen
zunächst im norden später auch in der
mitte regen im süden teils sonnig teils
ich drück nachmittags im norden wieder
größere auflockerungen
höchstwerte 15 grad und die weiteren
aussichten am montag bei drei bis acht
grad im norden sonne sonst trüb und
örtlich sprühregen
danach ruhigeres wetter mit vielen
wolken nebel und etwas sonne bei zwei
bis neun grad
erst von uns an diesem samstagabend mit
dem aktuellen sportstudio geht es gleich
weiter um 0.25 gibt es dann die nächste
heute express und uns morgen wieder bis
dahin auf wiedersehen wieder sind
[Musik]